>>> FOR THE SECOND TIME IN A
MATTER OF DAYS, THE WORLD HAS
GOTTEN A GLIMPSE OF KIM
JONG-UN'S DAUGHTER.
IT HAS RAISED QUESTIONS WHY SHE
IS APPEARING IN PUBLIC,
APPEARING IN PUBLIC NOW, IT'S
ALSO FUELLED SPECULATION OVER
HIS POTENTIAL SUCCESSION PLANS.
IN ONE PHOTO RELEASED BY STATE
MEDIA.
THE FATHER AND DAUGHTER PAIR
WERE SEEN POSING BY A TRUCK
LOADED WITH A LARGE
INTERCONTINENTAL BALLISTIC
MISSILE.
SHE WAS SEEN AT A TEST SITE WITH
HER DAD IN RECENT DAYS.
JOINING US TO TALK ABOUT THIS IS
NEWS WEEK COLUMNIST GORDON
CHANG.
I JUST WANT TO START WITH WHAT
WE ARE SEEING WITH HIS DAUGHTER
APPEARING IN PUBLIC.
BECAUSE IT'S A BREAK FROM
PRECEDENT OF WHAT WE'VE SEEN
PAST LEADERS IN NORTH KOREA DO
WHERE TYPICALLY THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN SEEN WITH THEIR CHILDREN
UNLESS THEY'RE THE SUCCESSOR.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> THE LIKELY EXPLANATION IS SHE
IS THE SUCCESSOR.
BUT THIS IS NORTH KOREA.
SO THE MOST COMMON SENSE ANSWER
IS PROBABLY WRONG.
IT COULD ALSO DO WITH KIM'S
SISTER, WHO IS EXTREMELY CAPABLE
AND SEEMINGLY AMBITIOUS.
AND MAYBE KIM JONG-UN IS TELLING
HER TO BACK AWAY, FORGET ABOUT
TAKING OVER IF KIM JONG-UN
PASSES.
REMEMBER, KIM JONG-UN IS A
SERIES OF MEDICAL PROBLEMS.
DIABETES, HEART ISSUES, SOME
OTHER THINGS AS WELL.
SO SUCCESSION IS A MATTER OF
SOME IMPORTANCE IN NORTH KOREA
RIGHT NOW.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WE JUST LEARNED ABOUT HIS
DAUGHTER NOT THAT LONG AGO FROM
DENNIS RODMAN.
WE DIDN'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT HER.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW AND WHAT HAVE
YOU LEARNED?
THE PHOTOS ARE BEING RELEASED BY
STATE MEDIA, IT SEEMS QUITE
INTENTIONAL.
>> WE DON'T KNOW MUCH EXCEPT
SHE'S PROBABLY 9 OR 10 YEARS
OLD.
RODMAN IS THE REASON WHY WE KNOW
HER NAME.
AND THE THING THAT'S REALLY
INTERESTING ABOUT THESE PHOTOS
IS THAT THE MOTHER, WHO WAS WITH
THEM AT THE TIME, IS NOT IN THE
PICTURES.
SO, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THAT MEANS.
BUT RIGHT NOW, WE KNOW VERY
LITTLE, EXCEPT THAT KIM JONG-UN
HAS THREE CHILDREN, THEY'RE ALL
VERY YOUNG.
NONE OF THEM ARE AT THE POINT
THEY COULD ACTUALLY BE GROOMED
FOR SUCCESSION.
SO THE DESIGNATION OF ONE OF
THEM IS REALLY UNUSUAL.
>> WELL, THIS, COUPLED WITH WHAT
KIM JONG-UN AND THE REGIME SAID
OVER THE WEEKEND, VERY
EXPLICITLY ABOUT WANTING TO BE
THE FOREMOST WORLD NUCLEAR
POWER, I MEAN, HOW DO YOU THINK
THAT THIS TIES INTO THAT?
>> WELL, THE PICTURES OF THE
DAUGHTER ARE BOTH IN CONNECTION
WITH THE 17, WHICH IS AN
INTERCONTINENTAL BALLISTIC
MISSILE, TESTED THREE TIMES,
SUCCESSFUL TWICE, THIS IS A
MISSILE THAT CAN REACH ANY PART
OF THE UNITED STATES.
OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE NORTH KOREA IS
SO SMALL, IT'S ECONOMY IS WUNY.
IT COULD NEVER HAVE THE WORLD'S
LARGEST ARSENAL, WHICH IS WHAT
KIM JONG-UN WAS BRAGGING ABOUT.
BUT REMEMBER, KIM IS A PROXY FOR
WHAT COULD BE THE WORLD'S
LARGEST ARSENALS TOGETHER, WHICH
IS CHINA AND RUSSIA.
SO WE HAVE TO BE CONCERNED THAT
KIM JONG-UN IS SIGNALING THAT HE
HAS THE SUPPORT OF BOTH BEIJING
AND MOSCOW.
>> GOOD MORNING, GORDON.
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THESE
PROTESTS IN CHINA AND HONG KONG.
YOU WORKED FOR ALMOST TWO
DECADES THERE AND THIS IS WHAT
YOU TWEETED ON SUNDAY, THE THIRD
CHINESE REVOLUTION HAS STARTED.
HOW SIGNIFICANT ARE THE
PROTESTS, AND HOW DOES IT
COMPARE TO PREVIOUS PROTESTS IN
YEARS PAST.
>> THIS IS SERIOUS FOR THE
COMMUNIST PARTY.
MANY PEOPLE COMPARE THEM TO
1989, BUT I THINK THEY'RE MORE
SERIOUS THAN THAT.
THEY GO BACK TO 1949.
1949 IS WHEN THE COMMUNISTS TOOK
POWER.
THEY TOOK POWER DESPITE
CONFRONTING A SUPERIOR FORCE,
AND THE NATIONALIST FORCES
MELTED AWAY BECAUSE AS ONE GREAT
CHINESE HISTORIAN SAID, THE
NATIONALISTS HAD LOST PEOPLE'S
HEARTS.
WHAT WE SAW SINCE THURSDAY WITH
THE PROTESTS OVER THE FIRE IS
THAT THE COMMUNIST PARTY LOST
THE HEARTS OF THE PEOPLE.
IN 1989 PROTESTERS DIDN'T DEMAND
THE COMMUNIST PARTY LEAVE POWER.
THEY'RE DOING IT RIGHT NOW ON
THE STREETS IN CHINA.
THE COMMUNIST PARTY HAS TO BE
CONCERNED.
>> IS THAT THE KEY DIFFERENCE
SOME OF THEM ARE WILLING TO SAY
THAT XI JINPING SHOULD STEP
DOWN?
>> YES.
REMEMBER THEY DO THIS AT GREAT
RISK TO THEMSELVES BECAUSE CHINA
IS A TOTAL SURVEILLANCE STATE.
THE COMMUNIST PARTY CAN
RECOGNIZE EVERYBODY IN THE
CROWD, WHAT THEY'RE SAYING,
DOING, AND WHAT THEY'RE DOING
CAN PUT THEM AWAY FOR DECADES.
SO THERE'S A BOLDNESS IN THE
CHINESE PEOPLE RIGHT NOW.
IT CAN FADE, IT COULD VERY WELL
FADE BECAUSE OF THE ANGER OVER
THE FIRE CAN DISSIPATE.
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT THIS WILL
COME BACK, BECAUSE THE CHINESE
PEOPLE HAVE MADE IT VERY CLEAR,
THEY DID NOT WANT THE COMMUNIST
PARTY AND THEY DON'T WANT XI
JINPING AND THEY WANT TO GOVERN
THEMSELVES.
>> YOU WANT PRESIDENT BIDEN TO
WEIGH IN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK HE SHOULD SAY
HERE?
>> I THINK HE SHOULD PRIVATELY
SAY TO XI JINPING, THAT THE USE
OF FORCE AGAINST THE CHINESE
PEOPLE WILL RESULT IN SEVERE
CONSEQUENCES.
LIKE THE SEVERING OF RELATIONS
WITH CHINA.
IT'S IN OUR INTERESTS TO MAKE
SURE THIS IS RESOLVED
PEACEFULLY.
AND I HOPE THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
WHO HAS CONCENTRATED ON WORKING
WITH ALLIES IS ON THE PHONE WITH
OUR FRIENDS AND PARTNERS AROUND
THE WORLD TO GET THEM TO SAY THE
SAME THINGS TO CHINA.
WE DO NOT NEED ANOTHER TIANANMEN
SQUARE MASSACRE AND DON'T NEED
SOMEONE LIKE GEORGE H.W. BUSH
TELLING THE CHINESE LEADER THAT
IT'S OKAY YOU KILL THE CHINESE
PEOPLE.
THAT'S MORALLY WRONG.
>> CAN THAT SUCCESSFULLY BE DONE
WHEN YOU HAVE, FOR EXAMPLE, THE
GERMAN CHANCELLOR, WHO WAS JUST
THERE, AND JUST MADE ANOTHER BIG
ECONOMIC DEAL WITH CHINA?
IF YOU HAVE THE U.S. SAYING ONE
THING AND YET OUR ALLIES, BIG
ECONOMIES IN EUROPE, STILL, YOU
KNOW, HAVING THESE INCREASING
TIES TO CHINA?
WHAT MESSAGE DOES THAT SEND?
>> YEAH.
CHANCELLOR SCHULTZ'S VISIT TO
BEIJING WAS CERTAINLY
DISAPPOINTING.
BUT WE HAVE TO REMEMBER THE
CHINESE AND EUROPEANS WERE SET
TO HAVE THIS COMPREHENSIVE
AGREEMENT ON INVESTMENT IN 2020,
WHICH WAS A SLAP TO THEN
INCOMING PRESIDENT BIDEN.
AND THE CHINESE, THROUGH JUST
TERRIBLE DIPLOMACY PUSHED THE
EUROPEANS AWAY.
THEY'RE GOING TO DO THAT AGAIN,
POPPY.
SO I THINK THAT THE UNITED
STATES CAN EXERCISE A LOT OF
INFLUENCE.
AND REMEMBER, RIGHT NOW THE
RUSSIANS AND THE CHINESE ARE
WORKING TOGETHER, AND THAT MEANS
THAT IT'S EASIER FOR PRESIDENT
BIDEN TO GET THE WEST TO WORK
TOGETHER AS WELL.
>> GORDON CHANG, THANK YOU ON
ALL THESE FRONTS.